In short,
when it is no longer above the river, one hears
everything. I see how adolescence applauds
the little children who enjoy the fight.
For me, an impression is magic.
fighter forever
[Music]
[Applause]
funding
my numbers many pains fields at
wembley most of them work in different
jobs as a cook construction
followers and take their time to
dedicate it to wrestling
there are like 178 countries mexico right
puerto rico  italy spain
dominican republic like the united nations but
from the fight exactly I deal with these
issues but you left us my amber ringtone
when I arrived at my moment
noon bronco already attacked so I
accept it very formally
I did not think that this character this
name was going to arrive  so far away and sometimes
I forget since I'm Francisco that
in my name I don't feel super super
proud of the name I bear  or as
international bronco
[Music]